it seems like a pretty consistent
positive benefit if you are trying to
enhance satiety to a meal it's just
slowing down a little bit
other tips i usually give people
aside from eating more slowly would be
avoiding really hyper palatable meals
while you're dieting structuring your
meals with plenty of protein plenty of
fiber plenty of water content and when
you do that when you have high protein
high fiber high water content you're
usually going to find that the energy
density of the meal tends to be pretty
low
and then just including plenty of
unprocessed or minimally processed foods
which again if you're including a lot of
unprocessed or minimally processed foods
you're more likely to include plenty of
foods with lower energy density and with
harder texture
and that's not a hard and fast rule you
can find exceptions to that but if you
are constructing a diet that has a lot
of unprocessed food uh or minimally
processed um and what you're going to
find is a lot of items in there with low
energy density and harder texture so
you're going to be chewing more it's
going to be more bites per meal it's
going to slow down the rate of eating so
there are a lot of things we can focus
on if we're trying to increase satiety
those are the ones that i focus on when
it comes to just what you're putting on
your plate
but one other thing i encourage people
to consider
is adopting more of an acceptance-based
approach to hunger so if you're
embarking on a weight loss diet
or you're trying to maintain a reduced
body weight
you kind of know going into that that
hunger might be an issue it might be
something that you are going to
experience
and
you know have to work through and so
there's really two ways to approach that
if you want to kind of dichotomize it
one would be i am waging war on hunger
and i need to fight this every step of
the way
it is a rejection of hunger it is kind
of classifying and internalizing hunger
as being an objectively negative thing
that you must fight against
and hopefully overcome and kind of
defeat
but if you adopt a more acceptance-based
approach
it's just a shift in mindset uh and
there's some interesting research
showing this to be a pretty effective
strategy when it comes to
experiencing hunger in the context of
dieting
but the idea is that you are accepting
hunger as part of the process now it
doesn't mean you're going to
be excited about it and enjoy hunger
when it's happening but it's a
completely different mindset where
you're focused on
uh acknowledging that hunger
experiencing it not forcing it to go
away not you know waging war on that
hunger but just kind of accepting that
as part of the process and trying to
reframe that and
if you dig into it and you take this
acceptance focused approach to hunger uh
you can find yourself almost looking for
a bit of a silver lining there right so
if you are dieting and you notice some
hunger the first thing you can recognize
is okay this is present and i know that
it's not permanent you know it's going
to come and go when i eat and fast and
you know
periods between meals it'll come and go
so it's not permanent it's not going to
be here forever it's not something that
necessarily requires immediate action
and it also could potentially be
indicative of the fact that i'm
generally on the right track here you
know i'm in an energy deficit and hunger
is one clue
that here i am you know eating a lower
calorie intake which is compatible with
my goal whether it's weight loss or
maintenance of a reduced body weight uh
so i it's it's not that i'm saying
you know the initial question was about
you know fat and satiety it's not that
i'm saying you know there's nothing we
can do about satiety because i think
there are a lot of things when it comes
to satiety and hunger that we can focus
on which can be quite helpful whether it
comes to how we construct a meal or how
we view hunger and satiety in general
but a lot of times the question does end
up being
fat versus carbs go or is protein
actually satiating and i think those are
i understand where the questions come
from but i think if we dig deeper we can
ask more nuanced questions
and when we do that we get answers that
are very practical very actionable and a
lot more helpful than just focusing on
macronutrient breakdown